over the past few weeks there have been
a ton of whisperings about blood-borne -
most of them fueled by this doll you
find in de Rosnay from software's new vr
title you reckon it's trying to tell us
something it is making contact after all
and this doll is definitely the same one
as in blood-borne the question you have
to ask yourself is does this confirm
blood-borne to Bruce Vardi just tricking
me into watching his dare a snake
content here's the dolls description a
doll of the stone girl Fiona who appears
in the unfinished tale when a person has
a bad dream
Fiona appears and helps them flee the
name Fiona is likely a homage to Fiona
MacLeod whose poetry inspired de Rosnay
but regardless of the name this is still
our plain old doll from blood-borne who
appears in a terrible dream and who
helps us survive the night but most
notably they say this doll appears in
the unfinished tale and this quote is
where things get interesting at first I
thought this doll was just an easter egg
right just a mention of blood-borne but
now it feels like they're trying to tell
us something
and calling blood-borne unfinished could
really mean two things
I think first it could mean that they
consider the story unfinished and that
they plan on finishing it or they could
be saying that they have no plans of
finishing it and the blood bone is just
designed to be an unfinished story
because some stories are unfinished by
design this allows the player to fill in
the gaps for themselves and think up a
satisfying conclusion to their favorite
series at the end of Dark Souls 3 for
example when you head into the painting
to escape a dying world you have no idea
where the story could go and that's a
nice ending in a way blood-borne 2 has
very open endings so remember calling
blood-borne an unfinished doesn't
confirm blood-borne - but it has made it
more likely personally I think from
software is saying we aren't done with
blood-borne
and our work is yet to be finished I
think it's less of a question of whether
they want to do it and I think it's more
a question of
when earlier this year Miyazaki said
there was no plan for more Dark Souls or
blood-borne games however he also said
he would be open to the possibility of
doing sequels in the future and since
Sony was impressed by blood-borne sales
and clearly values the IP I think that's
most likely where we stand I think they
have an idea for what they'd like to do
with blood-borne and while I doubt that
it's in super active development right
now I bet we'll see more from this
series at least in time for the
PlayStation 5 which is estimated to
release in 2020 because blood-borne is a
really strong IP to drive hardware sales
with so if blood-borne were to have a
sequel where would the story go next
well there are actually more clues in de
Rosnay so by the river of prayer in a
scene where you Lia cradles some living
things and then sets them adrift down
the river we find this statuette of
something called a seafaring sage a
statuette of a seafaring sage that
appears in an unfinished tale it is said
to appear in bad dreams to watch over
those who attempts to leave so obviously
this description mirrors that of the
Fiona doll and these two characters
together bring back memories of the
childhoods beginning ending which is the
one where the doll cradles us after
defeating the moon presence after we've
become an infant great one
in fact this ending is actually
referenced in darris honors credits as
well which proves that the seafaring
sage is indeed our player character when
we were reborn as an infant great one so
in the same breath that from software is
calling blood-borne unfinished they're
also specifically referencing this
ending that seems pretty curious right
all of a sudden this ending feels very
canon to me and if the description is to
be taken literally then our character
like the doll will henceforth appear in
bad dreams to watch over those who leave
the dream this always was the most
significant ending of blood-borne after
all it's the ending where our character
becomes able to lift humanity into its
next
hood and maybe it will sort of help
humanity go toe-to-toe with some of the
great ones and calling us a seafaring
sage is also interesting obviously this
is just speculation but perhaps the word
seafaring means that we can cross the
Seas to other lands and I've always
thought that a blood-borne - sequel
would kind of need to branch out to a
new setting in order to keep things
fresh
because unlike the souls games
blood-borne lively takes place in a
gothic Victorian setting which is like
an incredible setting don't get me wrong
but two games in one environment would
be a bit too much I think earlier this
year we actually speculated that shadows
die twice could potentially be a
blood-borne game based in feudal Japan
and while we were kind of wrong on that
I still would love to see how the great
ones could influence other parts of the
world and work their way into different
cultural folklore which brings us around
to what I think is the final blood-borne
reference in garrison II something that
hasn't been talked about too much online
just because of how Tim difficult it is
to find in game so towards the end of
the game tucked into Murray's folded
laundry is a book called blood and bones
it depicts this really tribal looking
warrior on the cover
who looks towards the Sun in the sky
with an eagle flying overhead and
another Eagle type of bird perched on
his shoulder his left hand looks as if
it's either holding or has been replaced
by two claws they look a lot like the
beasts claws of blood-borne the book
reads prose of some terrible tale this
fabled land of gold silver and
sacrifices owed both its rise and fall
to its inhuman warriors they applied
face paint brewed from blood giving them
the strength of the gods and carved up
their own bones crafting the weapons of
the gods if their legacy is neither here
nor there we're going into some deep
speculation territory on this one but
it's good speculation this theory that
I'm about to propose comes across pretty
well but I'm curious to see what do you
think so I'm going to try and convince
you that this book could be the
and setting for a new blood-borne title
or if not a blood-borne title at least a
new front software game so let's start
with those claws that were on the cover
if they are indeed the beasts claws from
blood-borne then that would make them a
weapon that has been crafted from the
bones of an undead dark beast the claws
and the dark beasts in blood-borne are
both found in the Loran chalice dungeon
and Loran is described as a tragic land
that was long ago devoured by the sands
and the description of an ancient desert
city devoured by the sands lines up with
a few other elements on the cover
everything from the enormous Sun in the
sky to the attire of the character to
the eagles soaring through the air so a
lot of the separate elements on the
cover actually mesh really well with
what we know about the Loran chalice
dungeon and I think the best theory that
you can get from all of this is that
it's possible that blood-borne 2 could
be a prequel and that it could be set in
Loran before it was consumed by the
sands again that's just speculation that
the concept and how well everything
works together there really makes me
excited Loran and the chalice dungeons
actually have a sort of architecture to
them which suits a lot of the
architecture in Mesoamerican cultures
like the Mayans and the Aztecs and the
Incans and as we'll talk about a lot of
the concepts in blood and bones actually
speak to those cultures but I'm gonna do
my best to put aside Loran and
blood-borne 2 for a moment and just try
to sort of convince you that the book is
at least referencing a lot of elements
of Mesoamerican culture so the Incans
the Mayans and the Aztecs a long time
ago some of you might remember there was
actually a spattering of rumors that
from software's next game was going to
be titled phantom whale and it was
apparently going to be a game with a
very minor Aztec aesthetic at the time
me and a lot of other people thought
these rumors were stupid as hell because
they were clearly overlapping with an
existing game called absolvo which you
might know of so I can't actually
believe I'm having second thoughts about
those rumors now
the few clues in this blood and bones
book really really matched the culture
of Mesoamerican tribes
so first the description mentions a
fabled land of gold and silver and the
peoples of ancient america endowed gold
with a very spiritual and symbolic
meaning for example the Inca thought of
gold as the rain of the Sun which was
considered a god to them and the Aztecs
who came after the Incans their
Emperor's controlled many mines and
workshops and they gifted gold objects
and ornaments to exceptionally brave
soldiers so that's one link the second
link is that the description goes on to
mention facepaint brood from blood and
these cultures did have an extensive
history of body decoration that's
probably one of the weaker links but
it's still a link but perhaps most
importantly the description mentions
sacrifice and inhuman warriors which
resonates really strongly with me so
America because a lot of these cultures
had strong military structures and a lot
of focus on sacrifice for the Aztecs in
particular their God of Sun and war
required regular nourishment and he got
that in the form of freshly harvested
human hearts and as the self proclaimed
people of the Sun the Aztecs
really victimized their neighboring
tribes one of which was called that flux
Carla people who ended up becoming the
bulk of the sacrifices that were made to
the sun-god of the Aztecs and in the end
this treatment of their neighbors may
well have been their downfall because
when the Spaniards invaded with the
intent of wiping out the Aztecs in the
early 16th century they formed alliances
with the neighboring tribes who hated
the Aztecs for very good reason
so they used that hatred of the Aztecs
to their advantage and they all
eventually overcame the Aztec
civilization and completely wiped it out
and you know why I'm mentioning this bit
of history it's because the Aztecs owed
their rise and fall - they're inhuman
warriors who terrorized and angered
their neighbors just like the book blood
and bones states so I'm actually not the
first one to think of a lot of these
connections a bunch of people over on
reddit have had similar thoughts as well
which I think lends a bit of credibility
to these theories and there's a lot of
excitement about this online or at least
I think there should be because of all
the video game settings think about it
Mayan and Aztec cultures get really
really scant representation and there's
a lot of unexplored potential there
especially since these civilizations
were kind of mysterious so personally my
fingers are crossed for some Aztec trick
weaponry or at least a return to the
world of blood-borne in the next few
years anyway before I go I want to let
you guys know that I'm finally going to
start streaming on Twitch don't worry
this won't affect youtube at all except
that I might shout out my stream a
little bit and maybe I'll debut some
videos over on Twitch with a live
audience I think that would be really
cool how often I stream will depend on
how much I end up liking it but I got
some fun ideas for streams I'd like to
do I really want to do a randomized run
of Dark Souls and some other modern
versions of the game and maybe just play
some games I enjoy playing in my free
time the most recent of which is
artifact the new card game by valve the
most fun part though has been designing
the stream I got to commission so much
art and when I commissioned a lot of art
and I have a lot of artwork coming at me
everyday that I can look at that makes
me really happy
and they have a sub button already I
have some emotes already which I'm
really happy with so go and check it out
and I'll see you next time for prepare
to cry they think